canon sur cette ryder cup alejandro
lampard lennon dans le sujet c'est
l'objectif ultime c'est sa mission à
long terme de façonner le parcours pour
la ryder cup c'est aussi une volonté de
la part de la communauté d'agglomération
de démocratiser de plus en plus en vue
de cette échéance
oui la sport au niveau de la communauté
d'agglomération souhaite profiter de la
ryder club de l'alstom open de france
pour que pour que les habitants puissent
voilà bénéficier de ces deux événements
mais aussi des deux golfs qui assurent
le bien sur le territoire on a deux gros
golf avec le coiffe nationale et le golf
de la base de loisirs il faut que les
habitants puissent en profiter et
bénéficier des retombées de ces deux
événements depuis l'attribution de la
ryder cup est ce que vous essayez de
combattre cette réputation qu'elle golf
qui est qu'il de réputation sport
élitiste entre guillemets c'est
difficile de la bourrée du sien
jugez sport de personnes passaient une
quarantaine d'années oui on essaye de
travailler à ça on organise des actions
pour l'épauler scolaire dans les écoles
primaires ont organisé des journées de
sensibilisation et on travaille avec la
fédération française de golf mais aussi
l'inspection académique pour que les
enseignants puissent suivre une
formation de golf et du coup intégré
cette cette pratique dans les cycles ps
on amène le week-end prochain le golf en
ville pour en parler voilà juste un
petit peu après on organise un week end
dédié une des premières animations
c'était cet hiver au golf national
puisque vous avez organisé une soirée
nocturne où les amateurs de swing et de
petit pouvait découvrir bad et swing
dans la nuit complète avec des balles
réfléchissantes reportages réalisés avec
des remises charpentier le swing à la
lampe frontale avec une balle
clignotantes une expérience inédite au
golf national en vue de la ryder cup
2018 et des sensations pour le moins
perturbante pour ses licenciés pourtant
joueurs aguerris du fairway
c'est assez surprenant les sensations
sont totalement différentes
la perception du de la géographie du
terrain est absolument impossible à
avoir et donc on joue un petit peu un
petit peu l'aveuglent les repères s'en
vont le point d'arrivée reste dans
l'obscurité et même les plus courtes
distances comme opting s'avère très
tortueuse pour les plus frileux
un simulateur de drive était aussi
installé dans le club house
les participants pouvaient aussi
s'essayer au swing virtuel sur les
consoles de jeux vidéo mais rien nouveau
le club dans la main c'est plus
difficile de jouer à la console pour moi
mais je pense que aussi jouer de nuit là
comme on l'a fait pour la première fois
c'est pas du tout ça très amusant mais
c'est quand même il faut il faut être
habitué c'est dès maintenant que la
ryder cup se prépare au golf national
plus de six millions d'euros sont prévus
pour aménager le parcours et le rendre
plus spectaculaire
un parcours que devrait fouler les
joueurs français après le titre mondial
chez les amateurs en 2010 la mission qui
leur est donné par le comité directeur
et par moi bien sûr ses délires les
enfants on à la ryder cup
mais si on a pas de français dans
l'équipe européenne
il y en a que douze membres c'est une
équipe réduite à les meilleurs européens
on aura raté quelque chose en attendant
d'avoir un français dans l'équipe
européenne en 2018
certains risquent de jouer jusqu'au bout
de la nuit à ne pas jouer avec toutes
ces animations se met en place au fur à
mesure vous sentez un petit frémissement
chez les saint quentinois qui
s'intéressent un petit peu au club
oui ça commence ça quand cela
l'opération qu'on avait organisé en
novembre dernier on a on a une une
approche assez insolite du golfe en
proposant cette pratique justement de
nuit et c'est vrai qu'on a rencontré un
franc succès puisque on a dû refuser
malheureusement il ya pas mal de
personnes malgré froid là on voit les
les journées de sensibilisation qu'on a
organisées auprès des scolaires on est
plus de 1000 enfants sur 5 jours le
week-end prochain on espère qu'on aura
du beau temps et pour permettre voilà
opus où plus de personnes possible de
prendre un club entre les mains et
pourquoi pas d'aller au golf le week-end
chez eux ou sur le sur l'open de france
voit ce que c'est que le golf avec des
vrais joueurs et la prochaine opération
c'est justement l'opération à vous de
jouer un qui va se dérouler du 28 au 30
avec un une opération un petit peu
spécial puisqu'il va y avoir le street
golf alors streetgolf pourquoi parce que
golf dans la ville c'est un week-end qui
s'organise en deux temps on a la soirée
le vendredi avec un parcours qui est
proposé dans les rues de saint quentin à
partir de 19h 30 premier départ donné
avec jean van de velde qui nous qui nous
fait la gentillesse de venir taper le
premier coup et tenter le trou puisque
ont installé un green ou flottant au
milieu de la pièce d'eau dans l'espace
saint quentin et puis après deux
journées d'animations samedi et dimanche
entre 11 heures et 19 heures ou là tout
le monde pourra découvrir les
différentes faces du golfe que soient
dupes thing de la proche avec les
ateliers encadrés par des stries de
golfeurs du practice sur l'eau et
comment on fait un parcours en ville
comme en ont fait un parcours en ville
alors déjà en équipe les gens et du
matériel par spéciale dans les terriers
qui me casse pas et qui ne blessent pas
on a fait appel un collectif qui
s'appelle le 19e trop qui
une des premières associations de street
golf en france qui organise ce genre de
deux parcours dans les rues de paris
assez régulièrement et donc on a
travaillé avec eux à l'identification de
six trous dans le centre de saint
quentin on ira jusqu'au jusqu'au par les
sources de la bière et les personnes par
équipe de quatre pour ôter toutes les 10
minutes partir prendre un départ si
jamais on n'a jamais pris un club de
golf entre ses mains on peut venir quand
même vous ça n'a vraiment réservé aux
amateurs un peu éclairé on peut venir
quand même je vous cache pas que si on a
déjà pris un club en main c'est plus ce
sera plus facile quoique ce qu'il ya une
certaine appréhension quand on est gold
peur de toucher le bitume avec un club
c'est quand même c'est quand même un peu
particulier mais
toulon s'est ouvert à tous et encadré de
toute façon par des pros par des pros
par les personnes qui ont l'habitude
d'organiser ce genre de parcours
une dernière question pour revenir sur
le sportif c'est par rapport à cette
ryder cup puisqu'il va y avoir des
améliorations parle beaucoup du trou
numéro 13 qui pourrait être un peu plus
spectaculaires sur ce parcours de
l'albatros il est prévu beaucoup de
travaux à aujourd'hui c'est à dire de
donner des détails sur ce que l'on va
réellement réalisé c'est un peu un peu
trop tôt maintenant il est vrai qu au
trou numéro 13 comme dans tous les
parcours de ryder cup
quand on arrive à la fin il ya la
dimension match-play donc la différence
avec le stroke play et en match play
c'est-à-dire là où un trou ne vaut qu'un
point on se dit que si on avance un peu
le départ du trou numéro 13 vous qu'on
en crée un des joueurs
d'une des deux équipes très habile
pourrait tenter le parc attend un cercle
au gicm ans sur un par 4 pour aller sur
le green volley hand au cou et là on
pourrait avancer un départ pour imaginer
qu'il le tapant avec beaucoup d'eau
maintenant on a cette idée là on a
tellement d'idées qu'on l'ait
rationalise on travaille on va déjà
fermé le parcours pendant plus d'un an
alors certainement en 2015 pour le
remettre à niveau tant pour l'irrigation
pour le drainage pour mettre des routes
pour la sécurité pour beaucoup beaucoup
de choses
et dans ce même temps quand on aura
finalisé les budgets pour faire simple
on va mettre tout sur la sécurité et
quand il ya de l'argent qui nous
resterons onfray sur l'amélioration du
parcours
maintenant la force d'un parcours de
golf comme pour l'open de france on est
capable de faire des petits travaux un
petit peu tous les ans pendant l'hiver
et ça apparaît pendant pour l'open de
france donc là on n'est pas arrêtée sur
certains travaux mais il est certain que
le parcours e évoluera ça deviendra en
dehors des petites améliorations un
parcours extraordinaire d'une qualité
par non non vus en france mais ça sera
quand même un parcours de ryder cup le
deuxième du continent
on suivra ça de près alors ces
évolutions versa en avant pour éviter de
nouvelles vraiment merci vos qu'olivier
d'être venu et puis bon open avec les
mercis aussi yann parce que si vous
venez nous parler de cette opération à
vous de jouer qui se déroule du 28 au 30
cette fin de semaine